the field goal might only be worth three
points but it's still one of the most
essential ways of scoring in American
football in 2000 1873 NFL games were
decided by three points or fewer more
than any other season in league history
so the kicker is responsible for making
field goals otherwise known as place
kickers are under a lot of pressure to
perform yeah there's a lot of stress
that goes into it you're either the hero
or you're the villain a well-placed kick
can make or break a game or sometimes
even a season and the longer a kickers
range the greater the strategic threat
they pose the NFL's most lethal place
kickers have sent balls flying through
the uprights from 40 50 even 60 yards
away in 2013 Matt Prater kicked the
longest field goal in NFL history when
he hit one from 64 yards now look a 64
yard field goal is already a tremendous
feat of athleticism but coaches players
and sports scientists all agree that
it's only a matter of time until someone
kicks one even farther potentially a lot
farther in practice some players have
made field goals from more than 80 yards
away but that's without any pads on
without a crowd cheering or booing at
you and without a defensive line doing
everything in its power to block your
kick what we wanted to know is what is
the absolute physical limit when it
comes to the field goal so today we're
gonna look at why making a field goal
from 90 yards away is almost impossible
to find out what it takes I talked with
one of the best place kickers on earth I
equated to golf or to baseball if things
aren't lined up it doesn't matter how
strong you are it's not gonna be as good
of a kick took a crack at hitting a 25
yarder myself and discuss the elements
of a perfect place kick with a bio
mechanist we need the ball to launch
with a high velocity right angle and be
accurate
Harrison Becker has mastered all of
those elements buckler is the starting
kicker for the Kansas City Chiefs and
he's known for having one of the most
powerful and most consistent kicks in
the NFL people don't realize how much
work we actually put in just because
can't come out and do a lot of kicks in
practice or even in the game doesn't
mean that there's a lot of stuff we
can't do on the side as far as watching
film taking care of our body doing
mental reps I mean kicking it a lot of
it is mental we met up at Kohl's kickin
camp in whitewater Wisconsin where he
talked me through the finer points of
place kicking back to Ford but also from
this kind of left-to-right motion from
back there all right before we get
started here's a summary of what a
typical field goal looks like straight
there's the snap the hold and the kick
all of which take place in about a
second so let's say this snap and hold
are good now let's look at how to
approach the ball you've got me here at
the 15-yard line so 15 plus 10 for the
end zone this is 25 yards a 5 yard field
goal right down the middle
I like your confidence in me yeah but
you got the soccer shoes army and maybe
even follow me and yes I was wearing
soccer shoes a lot of professionals
actually do that they were a soccer
cleat on their kicking foot because it
gives them a better feel for the ball
and a football cleats on their plant
foot to help them get better traction
but the truth is no shoe on earth was
gonna make up for my terrible form all
right so we need to get up the Buckner
gave me some tips
starting with my foot placement Oh your
plant foot you won faced and straight
down your target line and then you're
gonna want this your kicking foot to be
BAM perpendicular I was also using the
wrong part of my phone no you're gonna
want to have way up there that's what a
lot of people don't realize that we're
making contact with the ball all the way
up there that's the strongest part of
your foot right there on that bone
looking better high squash the point
that's good in high school that would
have been good exactly
too bad I'm 32 okay finally Buckner gave
me some tips on where to stand I had
been backing up way behind the ball
thinking that a running start would help
boost my power but Buckner says that's
not always the case the most important
thing is your contact so even if you're
sprinting up to the ball if your contact
isn't perfect then it doesn't matter how
much momentum you had because the
farther away I get the more opportunity
I had to mess up or
you know just being consistent really as
long as that last steps good you get
good contact with the most important
important thing but also in a game you
have one point three seconds from
standing still to making contact with
the ball so if you're super far away
it's gonna get blocked you know so you
kind of have to be closer as well Hey
last ball last ball we're out that was
great okay so I literally just kind of
put together all of the tips that you
gave me in the last second there I was
next
it was buckers turn why don't you show
me how this is done here now it's the
offseason for Bucer so he wasn't about
to blow his leg out showing me up still
he made it look effortless not the
greatest but it went through and once he
had warmed up he made it look just as
easy from fifty yards which makes sense
he's one of the best kickers on the
planet but why is bucer so good to find
out I talked to bio mechanist chase
Pfeiffer he stops their plant leg too
with his picking lay around in 2015
Pfeiffer developed an advanced motion
tracking system to help deconstruct the
flight of a field goal this help them
determine optimum foot speeds impact
locations and launch angle now there are
three things that really set vipers
research apartment number one most
studies on kicking have focused on
soccer not American football number two
most of those studies were performed
using two-dimensional analysis Viper's
analyses were done in three dimensions
which gave him a lot more insight into
the dynamics of player's kicks and
number three in addition to studying the
form of elite place kickers he also
built this
it's a field goal bot and unlike a human
kicker it can kick a football the exact
same way every single time humans are
unpredictable and a robot anything every
time by cross-referencing his player
data with his robot data FIFO was able
to analyze how things like foot
placement foot velocity and overall
coordination affect the quality of a
given kick the most important variable
of all impact location where a player's
foot makes contact with the ball
his research shows that the key to a
monstrous field goal boils down to two
things how much force you can deliver to
the ball and where you deliver that
force Pfeifer says that when an elite
place kickers foot makes contact it's
usually traveling between 42 and 49
miles per hour and that can deliver more
than 3000 Newton's of force to the ball
the faster your foot moves the faster
the ball leaves the ground and the
farther it travels now the ideal launch
angle for distance for a projectile as
any freshman physics student will tell
you is 45 degrees but when you account
for drag Pfeifer says the ideal launch
angle for a football toppling
end-over-end is actually closer to 43
degrees and to kick the ball at that
precise angle you need to kick it right
here about two and a half inches off the
ground or a quarter of the way up the
ball kicking the ball on this sweet spot
helps achieve the ideal launch angle
while minimizing the foot velocity
required to maximize distance in other
words hitting the ball right here lets
you kick it farther easier if you say
that's half way and the quarters about
right there that's generally where you
want to hit it I mean if you hit it a
little low it's gonna be a good ball
it's just gonna be spinning more but if
you hit it too high up that's when
you're gonna hit a line drive
knuckleball that precise combination of
power and foot placement is what enabled
Matt Prater to get the longest field
goal in NFL history in 2013 when he sent
the ball flying through the uprights
from 64 yards away now here's the thing
place kickers have actually been kicking
about that far for almost half a century
in 1970 Norlin Saints kicker Tom Dempsey
blasted a 63-yard game-winning field
goal against the Detroit Lions his
record stood for over 40 years and there
are a few things that make Dempsey's
record remarkable for one he was born
without any toes on his kicking foot and
was outfitted with this custom shoe well
it's unclear if that gave him an unfair
advantage the NFL eventually created a
rule that standardized kicking cleats
the other thing that's incredible
Dempsey's record is that since he said
it despite improvements in equipment and
training
almost nobody has been able to outdo him
at least not during a game and have the
players who have come close most of them
were kicking at Mile High Stadium in
Denver Colorado where balls fly farther
through the thin air Dempsey on the
other hand set his record at Tulane
Stadium in New Orleans just a few feet
above sea level since then nobody but
Prater has managed to kick the ball
farther during a game
but one thing kickers have improved over
the years their accuracy for as long as
the NFL has been keeping records on
field goals place kickers have been
hitting their marks more and more
consistently from every distance today's
NFL kickers are as successful from 50
yards as 1970s kickers were from 30 and
a lot of their accuracy has to do with
how they kick prior to the 1970s most
place kickers would run at the ball head
on and kick it with the tips of their
shoes it's called a toe kick and while
it can be powerful it is also
notoriously inaccurate but starting in
the late 60s players began making
contact with the ball high up on the
instep of their kicking foot the way a
soccer player would but you have a much
more consistent impact with that larger
area so the end result there being
increased accuracy by the mid 1970s most
place kickers had begun to favor the
soccer kick over the toe kick and today
nobody kicks at their toe at least not
in the NFL and that's because when it
comes to place kicking at the
professional level accuracy matters more
than power
guys in the NFL don't necessarily have
the strongest legs there's a lot of guys
in college that have these massive legs
that might not make it an NFL because
they don't have the accuracy you know so
if you want to have a long career you
got to be able to be consistent over a
long period of time once you're able to
kick with power place-kicking is
essentially a geometry problem the angle
of your kick needs to be steep enough to
clear the line of defenders trying to
block your kick and it needs to be
straight enough to avoid flying too far
left or right of the goal posts and the
farther from the field goal you get the
smaller your margin of error becomes a
20-yard field goal has to stay within a
seventeen and a half degree window to
count but from sixty yards that window
shrinks to just under six degrees so
you're hitting a 60 yard field goal if
that things slowly tilling to the right
you might miss that but if it was an
extra point that would be good if that
was a 40-yarder that would have been
good so you just have to be a lot more
accurate you might be wondering how
these guys handle that kind of pressure
the answer actually pretty well which
might be what sets pros apart from the
non professionals as soon as I started
jogging on that field I completely
forget about everything I ideally I
don't even hear the crowd noise and I'm
just focusing on what I can control and
there's research showing that the key to
success at that level is to replicate
gametime pressure during practice even
if it's just in your head what I like to
do in practice is I say okay I've I have
three or four balls I'm going to hit
from these spots I run on I mentally
almost try to envision that there's a
crowd there I try to put some pressure
on it and then also quality over
quantity so let's say a place kicker
comes along with unprecedented power and
accuracy how far could they
realistically kick and how precise would
they need to be for their kick to count
it turns out the answer to both of those
questions is pretty straightforward
according to Pfeiffer's calculations a
record-breaking 70 yard field goal kick
at sea level without wind would require
a foot speed of around 49 miles per hour
delivered directly to the ball sweet
spot and an 80 yarder will take a foot
speed of around 56 miles per hour and
both of those speeds are well within the
realm of current human ability
in fact the foot velocities of elite
soccer players have been clocked at more
than 60 miles per hour which in theory
is good enough for a 90-yard field goal
now it's true soccer players have a few
distinct advantages over place kickers
when it comes to kicking the ball far
number one they're not outfitted in full
pads which can really slow down your
foot velocity number two they're not
trying to clear a wall of gigantic
humans who can use their hands to block
your kick and number three unless
they're kicking a penalty kick they're
typically not performing in the same
sorts of high-stakes all-or-nothing
scenarios that place kickers are and yet
place kickers are definitely capable of
record shattering distances today check
out this footage of bucker blasting a
90-yard 4.4 second came time to kick off
but of course kickoffs don't need to be
as accurate so then the challenge
becomes placing that kind of kick
between the uprights while under the
pressure and constraints typical of a
field goal remember how the margin for
error shrinks the further away you get
well from 90 yards the window of your
lateral angle shrinks to just 3.9
degrees is it improbable yes impractical
absolutely in fact it's hard to even
conceive of a gametime scenario in which
any coach would even think to attempt a
field goal for more than 70 yards away
instead of going for say a Hail Mary
not that it hasn't happened in 2008
while playing for the Oakland Raiders
kicker Sebastian Janikowski was called
on to attempt a field goal from 76 yards
the farthest attempt in NFL history we
couldn't actually afford to pay the NFL
for the footage of that kick but just
take our word for it it came up short
the point is all of the factors are
there for somebody to come along and
kick a precedent shattering field goal I
would not be surprised that at some
point in my day I saw somebody kick a
upper-80s maybe even 90 I think they
could do 85 I mean guys are doing up to
90 yard kickoffs so why couldn't you do
an 85 yard field goal you know yeah I
definitely think 85
you could do if you had a really stiff
back when was a sunny warm day you had a
nice ball you had tall grass I mean
everything was perfect
the kt5 you could do but until all those
things line up remember that what
players like Harrison Bucer are doing
today is already almost impossible
[Applause]
[Music]